hey this is a bizarre and hilarious
story if it weren't also incredibly
scary Donald Trump is regularly
shredding and ripping up documents that
are legally supposed to be preserved
like the shredding that he's doing is in
violation of the law and staffers are
admitting that they walk around the
White House using scotch tape to put the
documents back together you couldn't
write a wackier Saturday Night Live skit
Trump staffers follow him around picking
up bits of paper and sticking them back
together with tape and Solomon lardy and
Reginald Young jr. spoke to Politico
about this they were formally in this
role --roll imagine putting pieces of
paper back together and they spoke to
Politico and said yeah this is this is
what we used to do and lardy was a quote
records management analyst which is just
when we think about George Orwell's 1984
can you think of a better term for
somebody who walks around behind Trump
taping pieces of paper back together
then a records management analyst with
30 years of experience he would use
exclusively the clear type of scotch
tape to look through piles of shredded
paper and put them back together like
jigsaw puzzles and what's going on is
that Donald Trump reportedly rips up
pieces of paper when he's done with them
and many are official documents that
need to be stored because of this law
called the presidential Records Act
which eventually gets sent to the
National Archives and to add even more
stupidity to it Trump would rip them up
and sometimes throw them on the floor
and staffers with decades of experience
would go around picking pieces of paper
up and taping them back together one
example from staffers is an official
letter from the Senate Majority Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer definitely
something that needs to be archived
Trump just ripped it up and tossed it on
the floor and the White House was asked
to comment about this and of course
we've gotten no comment from them at all
lardy and young the two staffers in
question they're no longer taping papers
back together but they did say that they
have not
as recently as a couple of months ago
that other people had been assigned to
tape papers back together that Donald
Trump had ripped up is anybody else
concerned that Trump is treated like a
little kid we know about propaganda a
clock twice a day Trump gets the stack
of papers basically a propaganda
briefing where it's pictures of him in
media looking powerful and strong it's
positive reports mostly from Fox News
and online right wing websites and in
addition to that treating Trump like a
kid we now find out that they're not
even trying to train him to stop ripping
up presidential records they just have a
team that tapes them back together and
when I think about how Trump even got
into this habit right like how does
someone how does a 71 year old adults
get into the habit of regularly
destroying documents related to the work
that he's doing I think it goes back to
Trump's business right it must have been
a regular habit of trumps from doing his
business at work that his instinct has
become to immediately delete or rip up
paper communications and it's been
ingrained in him from a career of I
guess obfuscation and possible
criminality but it's not normal it's not
normal and I I was thinking ahead to
when the Trump Presidential Library is
opened it would be great to have framed
papers that have clearly been taped back
together with scotch tape and then maybe
even bags of shredded documents that
would be a really great thing for the
Trump Presidential Library here's the
bag of papers that Trump shredded when
the North Korea deal went haywire and I
would love to hear from a trump
supporter write it I know that there are
Trump supporters who watch the show who
listen to the show get in touch with me
and explain how you defend this okay
tell me why it is that we shouldn't be
concerned that Donald Trump is ripping
up papers in violation of the
presidential Records Act and by the way
wasn't another one of trumps criticisms
of Hillary Clinton that she was wiping
hard drives and destroying records but
he's doing the exact same thing he's
using an unsecured mobile phone as we
reported a couple of weeks ago even
though he said he'll
Clinton's email server was the problem
he said Hillary Clinton was destroying
records and yet he's destroying records
and staffers are walking around after
him taping them back together with clear
scotch tape the one silver lining and I
like to try to find a silver lining the
one silver lining is that the documents
Trump has read and is ripping up are
probably not very long because we know
Donald Trump doesn't read long documents
I guess that's the silver lining that's
the only one I can come up with